[Music]
it's
God it's
God what's inside the Quran that make
you uh doubt it yes yeah so there's a
few things but here here's one important
thing okay um if we do you read you
speak Arabic I I understand it you
understand Arabic okay well I'm going
just use English for now you also uh
speak Arabic absolutely not no I'm I'm
from here
you know he's
also yeah I told him you read the Quran
more than us day so so so this is uh
something that's like important that I
see especially as a Christian okay so if
I go to serida I go to chapter 5 and
then um like 47 if I read verse 47 and
it says let the people of the Gospel
judge by what Allah has revealed therein
if any do fail to judge by what Allah
has revealed they are those who Rebel
right so it says let the people of the
Gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
there in in the gospel right so it's
telling me as a Christian I need to
judge by my gospel I need to believe in
it I need to follow it if I don't then
I'm rebelling against against God if I
do that okay cool so I read the gospel
when I read the gospel it tells me that
what's the gospel uh what Jesus preached
the writings of the message of Jesus so
basically like I have Luke 16 verse 16
yes a thing that's I do not I cannot
comprehend is why uh Luke or I don't
know I said I know
the Francisco and everyone why like who
gave them the the authority to say
something yeah go go to John 14 John
14 so Jesus tells us what's going to
happen cuz he goes away and he tells us
that while he goes away he's going to
actually send the Holy Spirit to help
guide the disciples to them are prophets
in a way yes yes cuz they're inspired by
God so you have um so this is the gospel
this is John chapter 14 but why uh a
prophet of God that you claim it's also
God need help from Ab bunch of other
people well that well that's like asking
why does Allah need help from other
people why does he send prophets why
doesn't he just talk to us himself no no
because we know uh Moses uh gave the his
uh
book yes everyone gave him like why this
from my knowledge this is the only one
with the different authors oh no so so
when when the quran's talking about
these different prophets right all of
those are different authors Moses is an
author yes right but the those are
prophets sent by God yeah and here the
the prophet is Jesus yeah so so uh if no
no I tell you because I was telling him
I'm uh I was really interested in uh
knowing this thing but in Italy people
are not religious at all okay so when
every time we talk about religion and we
try to you know have um these talks yeah
they don't know an answer any so I say
like What's the Trinity um I don't know
I just went to the church to told me
this Pokemon with my friends you know
the chance to play Pokemon no come on no
no in Italy no one even though we have
the the pope and we
have they just they just go to church
and they just like play yes so no one
have ever given me answers yeah I got
you well I'm glad God brought you to us
then so we could try to answer you but
look look at what Jesus says here so
Jesus says here he says um this is
Matthew 3 verse 34 oh look at you got it
highlighted actually that about my
brother oh yeah nice so look so this is
what Jesus says he says therefore indeed
I send you prophets and wise men and
scribes some of them you will kill and
crucify and some of them you will
Scourge in your synagogues and persecute
from City to city now see Jesus is
saying himself I send the prophets I'm
sending the scribes so Jesus is both God
and the prophet and he he is a prophet
sent by God and he also sent prophets so
let's break this down okay because this
is is showing that God is he's he's
we're talking about the Trinity here
right so you have the father who sends
the son yes so the son who's Jesus comes
down okay takes un flesh walks amongst
us and teaches us and he tells us who he
is he's the one who can send the
prophets that's who he is right so he's
walking amongst us as a man but telling
us who he truly is right and so as he's
telling us who he truly is is he also
tells us and lets us know that it's not
just him but it's also the father as
well and not just he and the father but
it's also the Holy Spirit as well which
is what he mentions a little later okay
this thing cannot be comprehended by my
brain well well it's it's we're talking
about God God is comp God is unlike
anything in creation right he Beyond us
we believe in Unicity of God in the what
Unicity I don't know if unique I think
you're saying Unity of God no he's only
one for us right okay but let's break
down why that wouldn't work okay for
example you we believe and I'm when I
say we I mean me and you we believe that
God is the greatest like being ever
right he's the greatest in every level
merciful he's most merciful loving he's
the most loving okay good so God doesn't
depend or need help with anyone right we
agree okay good so let me ask you this
then what would be the greater form of
love to just love yourself right you
love yourself you take care of yourself
which is a good thing that's cool but or
to also share your love with another
which form of love is greater selfish
love or shared love for us human beings
Shar shared love okay good so we can
conceive we can think of a greater form
of love than selfish love which is
shared love yes which means since God is
the greatest he by himself would also
have to have at least shared love he
would have to have greater than just
selfish love right because he's the
greatest if we can do it he for sure can
do it and better make sense kind I
follow you follow me okay good all right
so for God he has to at least have
shared love without depending on anybody
or anything so from your Viewpoint as a
Muslim God is only one person he's all
by himself in in in his nature Okay cool
so then who was he loving how did he
have shared love before there was
anything he's God he does not need like
we are uh social animals okay we people
where do we get our social our social n
from yes but no I I'm I'm telling you
for for like my answer for your question
is we are social and we need approval we
need to share things we like every form
of uh our life at the end of the day
it's uh social connection like work is
social connection relation relationships
family is that even when you are alone
and do something for yourself at the end
of of the day it's not for yourself 100%
okay but we are human and we also have
evil parts we also have uh uh a lot of
different things that God does not have
in himself negative right yes yeah okay
all the good virtues he has though right
yes okay but and for me like uh he can
be everything alone he can be the most
can he be the most loving yes how can he
be the most loving if he has nobody to
have shared love with because he's God
he does not need he know that he will uh
creates uh Angels boom there it is right
there he will create Angels or something
so that he can have that shared love so
that would mean that your the god of
like in your in your uh religion he
would be dependent on Creation in order
to have shared love he can't have it by
himself use the term uh dependence why
uh because I think that God is um uh
he's independ complete by himself and
perfect right see we we agree my point
is is that in order for him to be
complete by himself he in his own self
has to have the greatest form of love
without anyone
else this could be true but I I see it
more as um how do you say it um it's an
opinion no it's this is what we look we
we already know off the bat that's a
fact it's a fact that God is the
greatest okay okay we are we on the same
page so God is the greatest conceivable
thing whatever we can conceive he's the
greatest yes so if we can conceive if we
can think of a love that's greater than
just selfish love then God has to at
least have that greater form of
love it's a point of view for me he can
be complete alone and he decided to
create everything else but I don't think
that he created because he missed I I
agree I don't think I agree with you I
don't think that he creates out of need
right um like him creating us is
actually a blessing for us not him right
cuz we get to experience God and His
glory right so it's for us now However
the fact that when it in Islam your your
concept of God since he's a singular
person within his nature he doesn't have
um someone to have shared love with so
he he only has selfish
love his creation for sure but there's
no creation I'm talking about before
that ah before creation exactly so only
himself so the point is is that if God
is not
multi-personality okay then Allah can
only have selfish love he can't have
shared love and shared love is a greater
love than selfish love I don't I
disagree because I think that these kind
of things you can
only uh like if you talk about me we an
example I was born in a mountain alone
and I stay there my whole entire life
and I came here when I'm 24 I was like
who the are you guys like I know only
myself you know I love only myself I
have done everything for myself since
today because my knowledge is limitated
to myself in the mountain okay and I
don't know what shared love is what a
society is or what give to other to and
people giv to you but God
he knows everything he sees everything
he knows the future the past so I don't
think that while he was alone he needed
something else to be complete he will
one
day um create Angels Earth Heavens
everything else but I don't I disagree
with this thing that he needs someone
else to have a share love this this this
is my point is that with the trinity you
have the father Son and Holy Spirit who
together coexist and they're co-equal
and they share the one divine nature as
God right and so because of this because
they God is a trinity then shared love
and Cooperative love can exist within
the nature of God without needing to
create something to have shared love
with or needing something else you also
believe that before everything else
there was all also the it's the Trinity
Spirit yeah the Holy Spirit and and the
Holy Spirit is uh Gabriel no no no no no
no no he's not g Gabriel is an angel
angels are created the holy spirit is
the very spirit of God it's the he's the
spirit of God the Breath of God that
goes out and creates that God does
things by his power that's who the holy
spirit is so the Holy Spirit and he
speaks to the prophets uh the Holy spir
Spirit speaks to the prophets MH so it's
just the the word of God so so the word
of God is the one who is begotten from
the father he is the one who reveals God
through the Spirit by the spirit he does
this so so it's a messenger yes yes
messenger of the father so you don't
believe that uh Gabriel was the one that
speak with the Jesus no and with none of
other he Gabriel spoke with like Daniel
he spoke with Daniel he also came he's
another Prophet but it's there's an
Arabic uh
Dan I never agree okay so there's Daniel
yeah there's Daniel there's there's a
lot of prophets that the Quran doesn't
name yes no that we know that in the
Quran there's it's written that there's
plenty we know just few yep yep so you
have Daniel and the angel Gabriel comes
to Daniel you also have Mary the angel
came to Mary and uh her husband Joseph
as well um okay so you believe uh Mary
was married yes so she was not a virgin
she she was so she before she got
married she had she was a virgin she
conceived of Jesus and then she ended up
getting married after um okay right so
because God didn't want to like just you
know it's not going to be just for her
because she conceive his word then she's
going to have to stay with no man so God
allow her he told her in the gospel he
told her he told Joseph she's until she
You Don't Know Her Like You Don't going
to be know her as a man know his wife
until she bear the first child which is
is the word of God okay so after she
gave birth she married okay so Gabriel
is an angel a created angel he's not the
Holy Spirit nor does even the Quran say
that this is a a belief that came that
they developed even within Islam like
they developed this but it does there's
nowhere in the Quran that says that
Gabriel is the holy spirit right that
there there's nowhere in the K says that
for us Gabriel is a messenger mhm a dear
messenger like more powerful than the
other Angels yeah but he's not holy he's
an angel that uh do um delivers the
messages of God to the prophet yeah so
the Holy Spirit he not only he he
inspires the prophets to speak and give
Revelation but he also creates he also
um guides and gives comfort and that's
what Jesus says he says when I go away
the holy spirit is going to come and
he's going to bring to your remembrance
everything that I taught you and so
that's why Matthew Mark Luke and John
are able to write what they wrote cuz
they're inspired by the Holy Spirit to
write so the Holy Spirit was basically
guiding them while they writing their
right yeah okay yeah so so they they're
not just coming and doing this out of
their own whim and you know they no they
have the Holy Spirit they have God
guiding them to write what they wrote
and remember you know why uh the whole
um Bible was not written by Jesus
through Jesus well yeah Jesus was going
around preaching he have time to sit
down and and write you know he was going
around preaching his disciples they
scribed down what he wrote or preached
you know so yeah and he was only here
for like for 3 years he he he was on a
mission you know so yeah it it it makes
sense that his his disciples and like he
said he said I send you prophets and
scribes right and um and you're going to
persecute them so we see the scribes and
the prophets that Jesus himself sends I
was asking because how I said no one
ever gave me an explanation so it was
just out of curi yeah curiosity genuine
curiosity yeah so yeah so we have the
the Disciples of Jesus they're inspired
by the Holy Spirit how many they are
there well there's a lot there's 12 main
ones there are 12 main ones one of them
just betrayed him right Judas okay then
they replaced him after Jesus left they
replaced him with another but then they
made more like cuz Jesus told him go out
make more Disciples of all Nations so
more Apostles and displ came around like
Paul he wasn't originally with the 12 at
first he used to be a disbeliever he
went around persecuting those who
believed that Jesus was the Messiah
until Jesus appeared to him and now he's
a he was a Christian and became an
apostle of Christ and so you have Paul
you have James who at first did not
believe in Jesus and he's the brother he
was jesus' brother he did not believe in
him ah he's Jesus brother yes he was
Jesus brother James didn't believe in in
Jesus but then after after Jes Jesus
rose again resurrected he appeared to
James James became an apostle and a
Believer a leader in the church in
Jerusalem and so you have more disciples
and apostles being brought out through
the Holy Spirit believing in Jesus and
teaching and preaching the word
preaching the gospel spreading it which
is how we got the church what do you
think about Judaism Judaism as in today
today good I like you you cuz she said
in today cuz that's important cuz
today's Judaism is not first century
Judaism Okay so today's Judaism if
you're talking about Rabbi Jews they're
completely lost they they even they they
have what they call the to mood right
and um and they they'll related also
called the oral Torah so you have the
written Torah which is what we have
right with Moses and then they'll say
the oral Torah which is what their
rabbis teach or interpret of the Torah
or make up whatever they want right they
put that on the same level as the word
of God or even above it okay and they
are Lo that's lost you know you can't be
putting things above the word of God by
men that's not inspired by God not
prophets so yeah they're they're
completely and they they say Jesus you
know they call them all kinds of crazy
things it's uh interesting I've been to
Jerusalem oh wow two years ago I was
really really strong really strong for
sure yeah that's that's where everything
went down yes that's where you know
that's where they they persecuted the
Messiah our Christ now you believe he
was saved but yeah go ahead you don't
believe that Jesus Christ will come back
to earth we do yes you do yes he's going
to come back to earth he's going to we
do as well yes yes so that that's
something that we do have similarly
similarly as well is that we both
believe that Jesus is going to come back
however the missions of Jesus is going
to be different with what you believe
in you believe that he's going to break
the cross and kill pigs and whatnot and
he's going to come and do more than more
than just that he's yeah we believe he
he's going to bring peace to earth like
the
um essential of Peace like everyone can
live uh together without any wars
without any discrimination after after
the war though he's he's going to he's
going to bring War he's going to kill
the Antichrist the Antichrist and all
those disbelievers but then okay so in
this parts we uh do agree we agree he's
coming back yes also for the Antichrist
and for the anti yeah he's going to kill
him too he's going to embarrass him
humiliate him and then but but he's but
one there's a key thing that you guys
miss is that Jesus says that he's coming
he's going to judge he's going to judge
the world he's going to separate
Believers the sheep and the goats and
he's going to send the goats to Eternal
fire okay so uh you believe it will
happen on Earth yes he's going to come
to Earth he's going to crack the sky the
B look this is this is what the prophets
talked about before Jesus came in human
form the prophets talked about this
Prophet like you said you haven heard
Daniel Prophet Daniel um Prophet David
in the zabor right in the Psalms and
then also D yes d y and then uh Zacharia
I don't know if if that's familiar with
Zachariah he he talks a lot about this
he talks about how God is going to come
and he's going to come on Earth he's
going to land in Jerusalem yeah this
thing is yes okay so God's going to come
he's going to land on the Mount of
Olives what do you think of about this
crucifixion sorry what do you think
about his crucifixion I know you don't
as a Muslim you don't believe it's
crucified but we believe he was Ascend
ascended ascended to the heavens yeah
and that he will be back to bring peace
to the Earth uh after the Messiah so so
what do you think like happened at the
crucifixion we believe that uh Jew wants
to crucify him we believe that uh he was
persecuted that all his fellow friends
was persecuted and uh when uh they uh
want to put it put him like the the
moment he they want to put him on the
the on the cross Allah saves him yes he
himself was uh brought to the heaven and
another person was uh crucified in his
place got you interesting um that's the
main different I think what would you
think if the prophets foretold that the
Messiah would be CR if they prophesied
that the Messiah will be cruci
what would you think of that other
prophets mhm what would you think of
that I don't know you don't know yes cuz
cuz as this this is another thing that
this is why I like talking to Muslims is
because we we believe in the prophets we
believe that they have a consistent
message if it can be shown that the
prophets consistently told us hey guys
the messiah's coming and he's going to
give his life for you he's going to be
crucified he's going to die on the cross
for you that would show us if we
shouldn't be surprised when it happens
and if someone comes later and says
actually guys no it didn't happen then
that would mean that the prophets were
not prophets they were lying you know
God wasn't really speaking through them
and where can you find the this I told
you I like you I'm glad you asked that's
all you had to do is ask that so for
example um if you go if we go to dud
I'll go to dud in the zabor yeah and
we'll go to the Psalms
and we go to Psalm
22 so this is what he this is written
afterwards no before this is written a
thousand years before Jesus okay before
he came to Earth so he says
here uh I am poured out like water all
my bones are out of joint my heart is
like Wax it is melted within me my
strength is dried up like a pot shirt
and my tongue sticks to my jaws you have
brought me to the the dust of death for
dogs have surrounded me the congregation
of the wicked have en enclosed me that
means they surround him they pierced my
hands and my
feet I can count all my bones they look
and stare at me they divide my garments
among them and for my clothes they cast
lots meaning they gamble over his
clothes so here we see that David dud is
talking about the Messiah but who
written whoot this d d this is a Psalm
of D he wrote this um where does it say
this the chief uh sent the deer a Psalm
of David so David is writing this and
David being a prophet is prophetically
speaking about the Messiah this is the
uh Bible yeah this this is the zabor the
okay uh I don't know the difference
there's the old Bible the Old Testament
and the new test yeah and the Bible is
so the Bible is both so the Bible is the
Old Testament New Testament together
combined yes okay and there's no other
books no no the books no and also where
all the Matthew luk it's in the in the
newest y That's right so ja he's in Old
sorry another question the difference
between the old and the New Testaments
is like uh something
updated or like I I don't know the B
basically the Old Testament um you know
it establishes the history of Israel and
how God interacted with Israel and and
Mankind also it has the prophecies okay
so also Jews believe in the Old
Testament yes that's what they have yeah
and it's the uh what's the Tor yes it's
the old test that's the Old Testament
that's right so and the theore the
Psalms that's Old Testament that's by D
okay so this is what I'm reading I'm
reading the Psalms uhoh I'm reading the
Psalms which is Old Testament by dud and
dud is prophesying that the Messiah will
have his hands and his feet pierced and
that he and that they will gamble over
his clothes and so when we see this now
David D is is 1,000 years before Jesus
okay so we see that he's prophesying God
has revealed this to him that the
Messiah will suffer he will go through
this he'll be crucified okay right and
so if we have the prophets teaching us
this it should surprise us when Jesus
comes and he gets crucified and he says
that this is going to happen M now if
this and we see that it happens but then
Muhammad comes and tells us hey guys
actually you know what no scratch that
Allah saved them instead and replaced
them that would mean that all of this
that came before that pointed to the
crucifixion of the Messiah was a lie all
of it yes the main thing that's
um of course I don't believe in all the
all all the Christian scripts M
um because we believe that uh during
time it was um changed by humans and
that's the only thing in which I we
cannot um agree not because I don't
believe in like what you said to me but
the main thing is before so if that's so
now that's interesting point however so
we have we have the scripts right of the
Psalms
before Christianity started yeah so if
and they say the same thing right so it
couldn't be corrupted or like obviously
the Jews they don't believe in Jesus
right most of them they don't believe in
Jesus but it's written in here Jesus
exist why they don't believe in Jesus
because they just they also believe in
this hard Hearts hard heart even the
Quran talks about how they are stubborn
and hard-hearted right their hearts are
deviated you know that's what both the
Bible and the Quran say so people who
reject Jesus and reject the truth that's
presented to him just hard hearts and
and blinded eyes you know um it's
unfortunate but it is what it is now for
you know somebody like you and me we can
read this and take it for what it says
and believe choose to believe what God
has shown us or we reject what he says
and turn away from it and that's why I'm
presenting to you I want you and you
clearly you have a you're thinking you
have open mind I want you to consider
what the what the prophets have taught
that's why I don't want you to be like
the Jew and say oh well no that's been
corrupted but we have it before any
Christian was alive yeah as as uh you
know we believe in Jesus we believe in
everything else uh we do believe that
the only difference is that each period
of time people uh are corrupted and uh
they need a new as um Jesus was a new re
Revolution for uh Jews m M uh Jesus
Christ uh for us um Muhammad is the last
prophet but you know what Jesus never
here's something important cuz I like
what you're saying it's like you're so
close that's why I like everything
you're saying Jesus yes is a revolution
in his own self right for and for them
and bringing a revelation however his
Revelation that he brought never
contradicted what came before he
literally said hey if you believe Moses
you would believe me because Moses wrote
about me if you believe David you would
believe me cuz they wrote about me right
but we do believe in Jesus Christ we do
believe in you don't though at the same
time because you can't no no no no we
believe in him uh we just do not believe
that the recent script that we have on
hand are the one that was brought to him
directly and that's the you know it's
literally the main difference between us
so so and that that's the dilemma though
it will be strange if today as we solve
it here so I think it's uh like the main
difference is that we do believe in the
majority as we spoke it's I think go uh
half an hour we speak we have a lot of
things in common but the small things
that we these are core these are huge
yes the the thing that we do not um how
you say it uh disagree yes the thing we
disagree are small but huge in the same
time these are like the things we
disagree on are life and death they're
heaven and hell yes but the like the the
most most the majority we do agree the
the thing that Jesus is the son and for
us saying a son to God is uh I'll go to
hell for saying that yes but we do
believe of everything else like uh Mary
was uh uh was
virgin everything but these small things
are the the difference otherwise we
would have one religion my my my my
thing is this like these the these
things that we disagree they're not
small no no small in talking but huge in
the meaning okay okay I got you what
you're saying okay so then when we're
talking about if you're saying that like
okay yeah I see that Psalms said this
you believe that this was changed to say
this right that's your that's your
belief and you truly believe that okay
now if you truly believe that this is
why I have to I have to challenge you on
this okay I cuz I care about you I want
to challenge you to think if we have the
the Psalms right we have the text before
Christianity now the ones who would be
motivated we we do not believe that's
only uh the Christian test was corrupted
which is why which is why I'm going to
talk to you about this okay so CU we're
talking this is the Jewish text we're
talking about right in Psalms D yeah
also we do believe that's also Jews
before Christ before Jesus Christ uh was
came to Earth you believe they corrupted
it right all right but they would never
cor they don't believe in Jesus right
yes and main thing that we do believe so
pay attention to this and the first the
first Jews do believe in Jesus when
Jesus came to Earth few like the
righteous um I know followed him because
they know in the Torah was written that
uh prophets I know I know so so you're
saying the unrighteous Jews corrupted
their text right yes okay now the the
unrighteous Jews who reject Jesus they
corrupted their text would they corrupt
their text in favor of Jesus to make it
look like Jesus is is in their
scriptures or would they corrupt it to
make it look like he's not mentioned it
depend on what's the the
final on what the final so look if if
I'm if I'm an unrighteous je you
understand okay so I won't I won't
change like if I see a text and it's and
it looks like it's pointing to Jesus I'm
going to erase that and say let's get
rid of that take this one thing that I
do agree like for example uh there's
written that uh uh you cannot eat pork
okay yeah I think that the majority of
Christians don't know okay don't know
what that's uh you cannot eat pork no
that's the Old Testament yes and we're
we're in a New Covenant yes but it's an
update so so it's a the old Covenant is
fulfilled that its purpose is complete
we're under the law of the Messiah now
that's that's he brought the New
Covenant the new law okay okay so the
Old Testament was brought to m m yes and
and and the prophets before Jesus okay
so but the point is that I'm reaching is
no no sorry I just need want to finish I
was saying that I cannot take one part
in which I do agree and I say okay this
one is true but maybe in a few pages
there's something I do not agree and say
h maybe this one is corrupt you know I I
I'm not that uh intelligent or that I
don't know to decide what is true or
what is not I like what you just said
let me show you something about what the
Quran says
I'm okay just few minutes yeah just few
minutes and this is it I I promise I'm
telling you you are you're so freaking
close and and it's like you're you're
right there look at what the Quran says
here yes okay this is chapter 2 SAR Baka
85 right here it says after the so
talking about the Jews yeah after this
it is you the same people who slay
amongst yourselves and banish a party
from of you from their homes uh and
assist them against their enemies or
whatever in guilt and transgression and
if they come to you as captives you
Ransom them though it is not lawful for
you to banish them now here's the part
that's relevant then it is is it only
part of the book that you believe in and
reject the rest but what is the reward
of those among you who behave like this
but disgrace in this life and on the day
of judgment they shall be consigned to a
most Grievous uh chastisement punishment
for Allah is not unmindful of what you
do so Allah is telling the Jews are you
picking and choosing what you believe
you believe in this part but then say
you don't like that other part he say
you got right that's what you said
that's what what you what you said and
what Allah says goes against what all
the other Muslims do they'll pick and
choose what they like in the Bible and
say oh well this agrees with me this
agrees with me that one doesn't so
that's corrupted that one doesn't so
that's corrupted but this agrees with me
so that's good you're saying that you're
not doing that which I appreciate but
however this is what I need you I need
you to follow through with it okay if
you're not picking choosing yes then
Psalm 22 what I just read to you it's
either good or it's not and so if it's
good which the Quran points to it being
good right you have to we have to follow
it we have to believe in it no one can
corrupt Allah's words right but just a
question uh why do you use uh the Quran
you're musl no no no when uh you want me
to agree with something you use the
Quran to you know to push me but then
you say but Muhammad doesn't exist so no
no mam Muhammad exists I don't believe
in no no look this what I'm saying cuz
no it was just like so my my this is
your Authority right it's not mine so
the reason why I'm using it is because
you have to stick to this so it helps me
the Quran helps me helps you you know so
since you we do believe in what's like
it's uh truthful or not you you believe
it's truthful no you I I I I don't
believe that the Quran is truthful
however I do believe the Quran got some
things right okay now so you you also
choose no that's what I'm saying I'm not
saying that the Quran is is based in
truth I believe that it like for example
I believe that God like it's true that
there's only one God if the Quran says
there's only one God yeah got that right
now I'm not saying that that's based on
the Quran that truth is based
objectively somewhere else not based on
the Quran you get what I'm saying so
it's not my source of Truth you get what
I'm saying however it it it gets some
things right right so so maybe you just
uh answer my question is that what so
for me something things are true but not
because I like some the thing that um
are equal to the Quran because it's my
sort of truthness the thing that I find
uh similar to the Quran I do agree the
others I don't have the knowledge to um
but that's not what I said sister I I
didn't say it's because it agrees with
me that's how I know it's true like
you're you're you're saying if it agrees
with the Quran and since the Quran is my
truth which is what you it's subjective
to you that that's how you're judging
what is true or not but even the Quran
doesn't tell you to do that like the
Quran says to Muhammad in 10:94 okay he
says if you're in doubt about what we've
revealed to you meaning the Quran then
go and ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you yes so if Muhammad
is doubting the Quran how does he verify
the Quran the Bible no but the the but
if I found the thing that's uh the Quran
says this is yellow okay and the Bible
says the exact same thing is green for
me that I'm Muslim I will choose yellow
because I I cannot have uh you know um a
proper thing that I can go back in time
right but how so how would you judge
though how how would you because I'm
Muslim and as you are Christian that's
not how I'm judging though no no no uh
you are Christian and you do believe in
the word of Christianity for a reason
yes not because I just not cuz I'm just
a Christian because I inves I do believe
in what's uh Allah says and Muhammad
says and uh we when we uh are when we
agree on certain things uh for me it's
like it's really nice so answer this for
the thing that if it's opposite in one
book or the other because I'm Muslim I
would choose the the Quran and because
you're a Christian you will choose
obviously the the test you're missing it
the Quran doesn't tell you to choose the
Quran if it disagrees with the Bible it
tells you to choose the Bible okay but
if in the Quran there is written that uh
Jesus was not crucified I cannot go and
say I know in my opinion is crucified no
you have to be this is why the
quran's
yeah this point is super heavy and
important it's it's my favorite
Point okay I know you got to go so
here's the here's the point the point is
is that if there's a disagreement with
the Bible and Quran you know what the
the Quran tells you to do yeah go go
with the Bible but but I don't think if
the for example we do not have to eat
pork okay the easiest the thing that
everyone knows
about if I don't agree I cannot say ah
no I will eat it because uh Jew eat it
for example okay okay so I don't get
what you're saying I'm this is what I'm
saying I'm saying if the Quran is in
disagreement with the Bible yeah and it
says say that it came confirming the
Bible the Bible is true we have to judge
by the Bible because we uh believe that
is the uh confirm of what Jesus Christ
said then that's what they have not the
updates of the others but look that's
here's the point again it says that the
Quran that the Quran came confirming
what is with them in the wh what's with
them right so it's saying that they have
it not what's in that moment otherwise
Muhammad would not come if Christianity
would still be the the first one that
Jesus Christ taught to humanity we would
not need Muhammad so then why is it that
the Quran tells us in Muhammad's time to
judge by the gospel in Muhammad's time
the old one that we don't have to it's I
know it's just as I told you it's a
small but who's Muhammad's not talking
to Old Christians he says let the people
of the Gospel he's talking in his time
he says his time let the people of the
Gospel judge by it in his time but I
don't think I I think that's uh not you
misunderstand it but it's not exactly
this thing because what we read in the
Quran we as Muslim take it as true yeah
uh maybe you can read it to me in Arabic
because I don't oh you want me get the
Arab I'll get the Arabic for you yeah he
can no what do you need no no no no the
this thing that you said I I don't get
it I don't understand it the ver oh uh
5:47 Ser
47 that legits the people of the Gospel
to judge by what the Allah has been
revealed here and the people who do not
judge by what Allah has revealed are
transgression
okay and also you have a chapter 10 my
my brother mentioned
10:49 when he said like if he told him
like 94 94 sorry my my brother I told
him he's a half now yeah well here when
he's telling
him which is if you have a doubt which
is he's talking to Muhammad so if you
Muhammad has a doubt of what have
revealed to you go and ask the people of
the book to confirm your own Revelation
so that mean or Allah sending Muhammad
and the the gospel is a true so God send
Muhammad to confirm or if the gospel
corrupted before Muhammad so Allah
sending Muhammad to confirm from
corrupted gospel it's it's a problem
you know it's a problem so Allah is has
the clearly Allah thinks that the
scriptures are intact and preserved in
enough for Muhammad to go check them you
know to if he has doubts in the Quran so
they have to be true and if since
they're true Muhammad has to line up
with them now if Muhammad does not line
up with them right if what he's
receiving does not line up it doesn't
match then he'll know that what he's
receiving is not true cuz it Doesn't
line up with the Bible
and so that's what I'm saying the Quran
points you back to the Bible so if the
Bible says Jesus is crucified Jesus is
crucified if it says Jesus is the son of
God he's the son of God and the Quran is
wrong on these things that's that's the
Dilemma that's the problem of course
that's the problem also you have the
psalm my brother mentioned you have
Isaiah 53 you have Zariah you have
Daniel all these people that prophesies
about the coming Jesus because pretty
much the Old Testament when all these
prophets are prophesizing about the
messiah's coming then you have the New
Testament now the message of the Kingdom
of Heaven has came the Messiah is coming
the savior is come you already crucified
and died for our sins so now we need to
believe in him and his work on the cross
and then that the New Testament and even
if you L say leave the gospel leave the
Quran go on a historic like evidence and
Records outside both of the books like
you have uh uh Josephus he confirmed the
crucifixion you have the woman like a a
senator he's also confirmed the
crucifixion like even outside sources
outside this think um as I told you we
do believe that a crucifixion a
crucifixion was made we just don't
believe that Jesus himself was on the on
the the cross let's let's let her go cuz
we've been keep her a long time but um I
would I would like to say it was a
pleasure also for it was an absolute
pleasure talking to you um have you read
the New Testament at all a little bit
before try it no just a few few little
verses here and there yeah try it out
read through it I think that I think you
would find it interesting you you're
you're already interested in the stuff
already so check it out and I I would
love I I pray to God we meet again one
day and yeah insh
oh my God logic
[Music]